♪♪
-Good morning.
-Hi. Thank you.
-Diana Prince, cultural
anthropology and archaeology.
-Barbara Minerva,
geology, gemology, lithology,
and part-time cryptozoologist.
-Wow.
-I kept busy in college.
[ Telephone rings ]
Sorry. It's these heels.
You know? I just -- Stupid.
I don't know why
I was going to wear heels.
Scientists don't wear heels.
-Sometimes we do.
-Right.
Right.
-Have a nice day.
-Those are cool! I like those.
Animal print. Rowr. [ Laughs ]
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with the wonderful
Kristen Wiig.
That was a clip
from "Wonder Woman 1984."
I mean, I am so excited
for this movie.
It just looks amazing.
-I am so excited
for it to come out.
-Did you know --
You play Cheetah.
Did you know much
about the character?
-Um, I knew -- There's lots of
different versions of Cheetah
throughout the comic-book world.
So, when I knew I was
going to be playing the part,
I did kind of, like,
research a little bit.
Um, and I was like,
"Well, I wonder which one
it's going to be."
And then, you know, I mean,
just through the script
and talking with Patty,
we just sort of landed on this.
-Is it fun to be a villain?
-It's so fun.
-Yeah.
-It's so -- I never
get to do stuff like this.
It's so fun, yeah.
-Another thing that's really
exciting is you have a movie
you co-wrote with your writing
partner, Annie Mumolo,
"Barb and Star
Go to Vista Del Mar."
-Yes.
-Which is just an A-plus --
A-plus title.
-Just the title?
Okay, great. Okay, good.
-And this must be fun
to work with Annie again,
who you've written with
over the years.
-Yeah, it's -- She's, like,
my sister, my creative wife.
I mean, she's just like --
She's the greatest, yeah.
-You are Barb or you are Star?
-I'm Star.
-Okay, gotcha.
What does Star sound like?
-[Nasally] Star sort of,
like, talks like this.
[Normal voice]
We sound exactly alike.
We're basically the same person.
Um, but, yeah,
I'm really excited.
I'm not sure,
because of everything,
when it's coming out yet, but --
-You got to live in London
to make "Wonder Woman."
-Yes.
-Was that an
enjoyable experience?
-I love London.
I would live there in a second.
I -- I -- We were there, yeah,
for, like, I think
almost nine months total?
-Wow.
-Um, so, yeah, I felt like,
you know, a citizen.
-Do you feel like you learned
stuff while you were there?
-I did. That's a great segue.
-Oh, wow. Okay.
-Um, 'cause they have different
terms there and phrases.
Like, you would ask
for something and --
-Right. Like slang terms.
-They would have, like,
"Oh, put it in the trunk,"
and they're like, "What?"
And it's called a boot.
-Okay, got you.
-Okay. I have some ones
that I'm going to quiz you on.
-Oh, I'm excited.
-My dress doesn't move,
so this is really hard.
Okay. There we go.
All right, Seth.
What do you think
this is called?
-That is -- That is an elevator.
-It looks like a refrigerator.
Well, in England,
they call this a lift.
-Oh, okay. That's very helpful.
-People know this one.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-It makes sense.
-Okay.
-A stroller.
-They actually call this a pram.
-Okay. That's very helpful, too.
I think I knew that.
-Don't know where that
comes from.
'Cause you pram.
You pram down the street.
Um, okay.
-Uh. Oh, is that --
Is it eyeliner?
-Mm-hmm. But they call it coal.
-Coal?
-So if you were to ask your
makeup artist for some eyeliner,
they wouldn't know
what you were talking about.
-Okay, got you. All right.
-And this one's
a little controversial.
-It's an eraser?
-It's a rubber.
-Oh, that is controversial.
-It's called a rubber.
-You get some real innuendo.
-You can get in trouble. Yes.
-Okay, I know it's an apple,
but what do they call it?
-This is actually called
a bambablam.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't. No.
-Yep. Seth, I lived there.
-Okay.
-Okay?
-It's a bicycle?
-No, this is a whiffle waffle.
-A whiffle waffle?
-Yes.
I'm going to take a ride
on my whiffle waffle.
-I didn't --
I don't think that's true.
-It's true.
Um, and I also have a --
There's a couple phrases.
-Okay.
-I'm not sure --
'Cause you didn't live there,
so you might not know
what they are.
-Sure, sure, sure.
-There's a phrase called, "Have
you been to Pipper Willy's?"
-Okay.
Where is Pipper Willy's?
-It's not a where.
"Have you been
to Pipper Willy's?"
really translates to "Thank you,
but no thank you," in London.
-It seems like weird --
-That's how they say it.
-So if I used it in a sentence,
if I said to you, like,
"Can I get you another drink?"
-"Have you been
to Pipper Willy's?"
-That seems bad.
-It's true.
Um, and also your name, Seth...
-Oh.
-...would not be "Seth"
over there.
-Oh. What's "Seth" in London?
-It's Ray.
Everyone would call you Ray.
-So names have, like, a Br--
-Yours does.
Not -- Some names do.
-So what's "Kristen" in London?
-Just Kristen.
It's just Kristen.
-What's Ray?
-There's no --
If you went over there
and said your name was Ray,
they wouldn't know
what you were --
what you were talking about.
-This is so helpful.
-I mean, now you can go.
-Yeah.
Oh, and there's one final one
that you have to be really
careful you don't say.
-Oh, great.
-It's the word "fanny."
-Fanny. Gotcha.
Because it means --
-No.
-Okay. What does it mean?
-It's -- [Muttering]
[ Laughter ]
-So when I hear British people
say "fanny,"
that's what they've been
talking about?
Oh, my God! That was so --
-You can go now.
-I can go now.
-Now you'll feel --
Because I lived there, Seth,
so I know all this now.
-And you learned all of that
in nine months?
-Just that.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God, Kristen, thank you
so much for being here.
I cannot wait
for Saturday night.
-Thanks for having me.
I miss you.
-Check out "SNL" this weekend
with Kristen Wiig.
"Wonder Woman 1984"
is in select theaters and IMAX
December 25th
and is available the same day
on HBO Max.